il ya une nécessité de briser les
fêlures isation que nous avons
intériorisé
il ya une nécessité de réunir les
talents que nous avons que nous
possédons et de prendre en charge notre
devenir économique
les membres des communautés noires de
montréal se réunissent au forum
économique international des noirs pour
parler économie développement social et
d'entreprises épanouissement
professionnel et pour envisager un futur
plus prospère pour leurs jeunes talents
nos jeunes femmes nos jeunes hommes sont
leur doctorat ou la maîtrise ils ont
tout ce qu'il faut son ingénieur en
gardant notre valeur on a tout ce qu'il
faut
france télé
né à lacaune art peut travailler avec
les google et facebook et a pour les
stations seront les lg les mercedes de
bienvenue
j'arrête tous parce que mon niveau de
compétition
internationaux je ne suis ni
niveau
dans un environnement presque je devais
absolument
[Musique]
ce qui est meilleur
cette rencontre annuelle favorise le
partage du savoir des ressources et des
structures parfois manquantes pour
l'émergence de nouveaux leaders dans la
communauté marginalisée
nous avons les capacités de nous
épargnons par une capacité
d'émancipation et donc l'émancipation
économique est très importante on peut
parler de l'éducation peut parler de la
santé dont on a besoin pour voir prendre
soin de nous non seulement qu'on
consomme noir mais aussi de montrer les
avantages de ce que l'on a dans la
communauté et ainsi de suite et on avait
parlé de la créance et la création de
nouveaux ça fait déjà fait il ya je
crois vous savez le projet ch consomme
aux haïtiens qu'ils existent ça serait
peut-être aussi de l'année peut-être à
une plus grande échelle ou ce qu'on
pourrait parler le vraiment consommé
noir dont j'ai pas on peut donner un mot
un beau comeback là pour une compagnie
on pourrait avoir un logo qui serait
homologué sur des produits ou ce que les
gens pourraient aller dans n'importe
quelle épicerie pizza au hockey ça ça
vient de la compagnie ça rien à [ __ ]
les participants du forum assiste à des
dates de travail des conférences des
labos qui les aident à poser les bases
nécessaires à concrétiser leurs projets
professionnels et d'entreprise
il ya des chefs d'entreprise qui vit à
nice qu ils ont des problèmes que les
gens qui les ont aidés à
abete le cas sous la table mais que ce
ne sont pas ces gens là qui vont les
aider à prendre l'emprise un autre
niveau
si vous aidera les jeunes consultants
vous pouvez aller dans n'importe et en
produits frais ont regardé la crawford
dans les îles aux tirs moi ce que je
fais c'est que je crée la différence
pichon comprend team et possède des
compagnies privées celles que vous et
moi ici on peut se mettre en coopérative
et puis partir du vrai business
faut qu'on trouve une façon d'arriver à
mettre ensemble sur la même plateforme
nos affaires
faut qu'on retrouve d'économies dans
notre système ça prend une mentalité de
gagnant sa part une mentalité
de conquérant comprendre et à quelqu'un
comme ce soir
assumer
france j'avais tellement de pouvoir
politique si on n'a pas de pouvoir
économique